E aí galera que assiste o meu canal tudo
bom com vocês
aqui na Argentina agora a gente vai
fazer um treino de box para vocês ver
hoje a gente vai fazer manobrinha
governadora e dá uma corridinha na praia
[Música]
Talvez seja só
tá possível de lesão
vai tocar uma bola
[Música]
é o primeiro round trabalhamos golpes em
linha jegue direto somente aqui na
manopla para ele usar bastante essa
movimentação de tirar o Jeff colocar o
Jair entrar com Jair de encontro direto
de encontro
meio que um aquecimento a gente começou
a trabalhar nos golpes em linha aqui na
parada
[Música]
trabalho que a gente fez aí ele usou uma
ação um pouco mais realista então usei a
mão da frente com a luva para ele
bloquear para ele ativar ele tem um
ponto de foco na manopla E também o
colete para ele bater nele então ele tem
a noção de esquivar entrar golpe em cima
e meter a mão embaixo trabalho um
pouquinho mais real aí
[Música]
a gente repetir tanto que isso vai ficar
natural
só para o atleta
[Música]
terminamos a parte da manhã
onde a gente faz o treino de box e
depois uma corridinha no final para
encerrar né o Card a gente corre aqui
nessa
Orlando que ainda tem mais um treino
hoje
E aí nesse treino a gente mostra as
coisas do
Neymar não
a gente mostra os equipamentos para todo
mundo entender o que que é que a gente
usa e tal a galera quer saber
tô gravando aqui velho os cara não
respeita beleza mas é isso se você tiver
gostado clica no gostei
se não tiver gostado clica aí não gostei
não aparece mais no YouTube
ai ai ai ai ai que delícia Beleza vou
agora almoçar Parece que fica uma draga
no estômago da gente
vamos nessa
para o próximo vídeo
Tchau uma fase do box
E aí a gente volta ao normal mas vocês
tem que me acompanhar em qualquer
momento